perché ma questo rumore sinistro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
bentornati svanito statistiche ci
chiedete da più di un anno peggior ella
si boreale versus cioccolato challenge
indovinate chi e pensiamo di fare questa
azione non vedi che vidal è un mangione
emesso quindi si sa che gli capiti cibo
normale siete mica per il cibo sconto
sarà felicissimo a perché non gli capiti
perché non solo strascico ma c'erano
anche agenti veri e di cioccolato tra
fate il tifo ott in giallo ottimo rosso
se volete vedere altri video di cibo
qualcun altro lo so vi farete molto
contenti lasciato un bel lega punto di
vista questo video delusissimi alex
andremo a farne un altro per favore
perché io
mangiare ma quanto è felice invece
religioni pausa si recò corner e
iniziamo subito alla fine del video
potete dirci qual è la cosa di
cioccolate vi è piaciuta di più che
vorreste mangiare anche un po bene e
siamo ok primo round in ogni round una
volta a testa potremo decidere se
vogliamo scambiare la cloche o no vabbè
la tengo per 3 2 1 o turno abbiamo
telefono di cioccolato contro il
telefono vero carbonaro corredate
cliccare quindi eccolo qua è bellissimo
mi dispiace quasi montaldo oppure sono
super curiosa di vedere come e io no
tuttavia maggio con loro
[Musica]
quindi è solo disegnato da un buono
stato mandato in telefono mi voglio
mancare il pulsante io voglio assaggiare
per assaggiare no proprio no mio cattivo
o acqua ci teniamo bene per il prossimo
round impronta sono prontissima milano
mangiando il semi odierno
ok prossimo round che non facciamo ora
lo tieni o lo cambi ok 321 come fece
niente festa però
guardate un po anche se a questo sempre
di cioccolato abbiamo il rossetto che
sembrano di cioccolato veramente invece
qui abbiamo il rossetto di cioccolato
quando sei contenta è tanto più belle
questo è il cioccolato al latte bianco e
fondente come nuovo abbiamo perso di un
doppiato si no mai detto tutto devo
iniziare nota noto allora terzo round
giusto lo tieni non cambi lo scambio
6sicuro 13 21
perché lei cioccolato
voglio vedere ecco perché lui era un
martello di cioccolato no non penso
si no spetta se vi capita la pizza è mai
non basta però ok ma cerca titolare 4
round devo decidere se tenerlo
scambiarlo lo tieni allo ska p
lo scambio per il livello dobbiamo
cambiarlo
[Musica]
3 2 1
insomma non lo so colato quindi continuo
con ciò che abbiamo la pizzera e la
notizia il corato bianco in pezzetti di
cioccolato nero la base che sembra
fantastica se so che sarà ospite di
quanto io no no da taglio con la mia
faccia tagliapizza sembra più rapidi
cioccolato bianco e cioccolato lo
diciamo rosanero cioccolato all'asse
però si sente pure ciò che vediamo è
invece quei pezzetti sopra questo strano
ma grosso dopo con l altro che questo
sia caramello nel questo sia di como il
cioccolato di un biscottino di paul
browne ok guarita
caramella caramello al caramello lastra
non guardo cosa così diverse
[Musica]
[Applauso]
talmente la pazza idea io su quella di
cioccolato poi con le piace di più per
aver operato una notte due una
sterminata scambiata a una mangia tutto
io posso capire tutte a formare un video
pop band marco bel times
mi piacerebbe mandarlo d'aiuti dopo
l'effetto di pizzato gradevole
va bene molto bene che tocca al 30 e
latte intanto l'abbiamo finito per la
mia mi passa tutto
abbiamo diviso di un utilizzo è
equamente perché io sono gentile mi
trovo
ci sono tre carmeli album buona passiamo
al prossimo mercato
va bene ok allora siccome prima vita
l'ha fatto due torri questa lieve
halloween questa volta secco io ho da
dire la catena lo tengo aspetta 3 2 1
[Musica]
scappa scappa
poi gigante e queste piccolina scarpa
era la mia gioia tauro
non so come faccia a camminare queste
scarpe io sono molto triste perché non è
quella di cioccolato però non mangiate a
scarpa nata mangia il tacco ma tu
attacco
andava sotto la strada te molto zucchero
cosa è stato serrato cabina o chimico lo
siamo perché l'ultima non è detto che
non darà mai domi gesto forse quinto
quinto io dico questo 5 allora toccate
essere bottini losca mi ok 32 cambiando
male che cosa abbiano una pizza l'era
che utilizzerò per toglierti neanche
dopo insieme ma vedrete che bella la mia
pizza le la mia philippsen cioccolato
andate e cioccolato fondente qua nella
mia invece c'era acciaio e plastica
mista tanto poco cominciato bene
cominciamo quasi precedentemente adesso
male da due turni abbiamo una fornitura
del cioccolato per un anno intero in
questo sa molto di cioccolato fondente
perché è una parte più posso farlo tutto
mio
ora tocca a me decidere se lo scambio lo
tengo visto perché non l'ho mai
scambiato lo scambio non è scritto asi
tardini 3 2 1 con gli occhiali da sole
di cioccolato io c'ho quelli veri
vediamo mi trovo come mi stanno piccoli
con date sono il suo colosso bianco e
cioccolato fondente che questi voglio
mangiare la pappa media mangiato
abbastanza per fare sta capitando a me
vediamo
[Musica]
vuoi cioccolato fondente al latte ci
credono identificate rimanere con gli
occhiali che non ha idea di che cosa
verrà addossiamo con per lo scambio lo
tieni
io lo tengo ok 321 sì anche la rotellina
della tesi anche la rotellina cioccolato
bianco caricare tutta la perte sei
mangiato subito guarda che borsetto
piccolo che gli hai dato è
[Musica]
sul supporto lei sentito il cioccolato
bianco
siccome le mete successi che però è
profuso insieme a tutto per tutto il
giorno portato alla fine a decidere di
cambiarlo ottenerlo
no noi cercare di capirlo lo scambio
321 è un pò diverso questo
effettivamente perché è un profumo che
il mio profumo però la scatolina è
diversa questo confido che cosa linea a
fino alle teorie cioccolato bianco
anch'io che possono aiutare ma era
invece morto del profumo la prossima
tropsch ha fatto il bianco ancor più
buono e profumato di cioccolato promessa
già allora ragazzi per te non per andare
in camera no chi sarà il fortunato
toccate insegnare latino scanu di cambio
possono dire lo scatto per un piazzato
[Musica]
perché non ha questo rumore sinistro
castani de bellis non sempre solare
carella ad essa ottimo buonissimo anche
sciannimanico di mescolanza yo e
plastica delizioso io invece non un
bellissimo caccia mente di cioccolato al
latte l'apparato bianco e cioccolato
nero
[Musica]
no no no emma è il pezzo l'ultimo giorno
a totti alla fine quante cioccolati
abbiamo mangiato a testa e'andato di
cioccolato tu io
meno male ma punteremo è andato troppo
guarda però dotate che mi ha fatto
divertire e prende la fase di crisi
sapete mi è piaciuto questo il sale se
volete vedere
è un'altra molti gli artisti premi
proventi in italia star a 20650 parlando
di cibo si sente e ora vi lasciamo
quattro cartelli su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video nella
sezione video divertenti cliccate su
quella che preferite televisione ciao